we believe that it may have involved a  knife that people were attacked with a  knife on London Bridge now the very  latest information I'm getting on this  is that aren't police officers have shot  a suspect that suspect you understand is  dead this is a very early stages of an  incident that is unfolding you know  we're actually heading to the scene  ourselves just very shortly but the  latest information that we've got is  that this incident happened on London  Bridge that an attacker with aren't we  believe with a knife started attacking  people that armed police were deployed  and that that attacker alleged the  attacker has now been shot and the  information that we're getting through  from sources is that he was fatally shot